new models mitosis on aging and there is
no question in this 21st century it's
going to be the most important
demographic the world is aging and we
have lost a lot of time we have to bring
aging into the agenda it is something
that impact devolved society what has my
counsel doing first thing is that last
year we made a decision of writing and
monograms so the different members of
the council are responsible for many
different chapters and we have reached
out to meet other councils and members
that are co-authors or main Walters of
this monograph on age and the new idea
that is emergent is that in the same way
that the baby boomers because they lived
in peace and affluence they have
developed the construction social
contract of adolescence now the baby
boomers this big generation reaching old
age will revamp aging as a transition in
the same way that we have invented or
created the notion of adolescence the
transition from childhood into adulthood
that used to be abrupt and now which is
a transition we are going to make a big
change in the social concept of aging
except that this transition is not going
to last five or six years it's going to
last two or three decades so there is a
lunch to watch and we are firmly
committed to that thank you